takanya and his wife walking around I
did just walking on the street him and
his fetching girlfriend just walked by
no one bothering them at all looked very
happy he was wearing his shoulder pads I
didn't bother him wodo and a funny thing
for me to say to him be like hey yay I'm
also on team Jeselnik I'm ground floor
on jeselco he would have taken you out
to dinner he would have given you
clothes you'd be dressed like Kanye
right now and you'd be happier or like I
think he would think was cool is if you
just like pointed at him and went Jesus
walks and then it's like followed him
around doing that over and over again
that would be funny or just like
flashing lights lights lights like I
think he would like I think he would he
seems like he'd be cool with that sort
of thing